Курсанти "вилітають" на одне зі своїх перших бойових завдань у якості пілотів дронів.
Усі екіпажі ваших колег, які з вами навчаються, - ми зараз проти них працюємо.
- Ага. - Шукаємо, де вони замаскувалися, збираємо фото, відео,
збираємо розвідматеріал.
10, 12, 13… Шістнадцять чоловік.
Юрія війна застала зі сноубордом у Карпатах.
До повномасштабного вторгнення він займався альпінізмом.
З дрона знімав на відео гірські походи. Тепер він навчає інших фільмувати ворожі позиції.
Яка висота у вас? Шість метрів? Він уже десь має бути. Знижуйтеся.
Я відчуваю, що я залучений в боротьбу, навчаю людей бути операторами дронів,
керувати квадрокоптерами… Уперше в своєму житті я став інструктором, вчителем.
У цій групі - і військові, які щойно приїхали з-під Бахмута, і цивільні,
які хочуть отримати нові навички. Дрони, з якими працюють курсанти,
називаються мультироторними. Нинішню війну інструктор Юрій
називає наймасштабнішим їхнім застосуванням в історії.
Уперше в такому обсязі вони працюють і в них багато сфер застосування.
Розвідка, коригування вогню, моніторинг проведення бою, скидування,
дрони-камікадзе, дрони-розмінувальники.
Нині в Україні працюють близько 20 шкіл операторів дронів.
У цьому навчальному центрі є кілька курсів. Цей - базовий, для початківців.
Триває лише п'ять днів.
Спершу курсанти навчаються на симуляторах. Тут можна відпрацювати моторику,
управління джойстиком. На лекціях пояснюють, які з дронів кращі, що необхідно для польотів.
У полі відпрацьовують тактику, вихід на позицію, навчаються працювати
з камерою і взаємодіяти з колегами.
Хлопці, ви мене випустите? Я туди!
Дмитро - професійний ведучий свят. Він ніколи не служив в армії.
Після повномасштабного вторгнення чоловік вступив у добровольче формування
територіальної громади, згодом став командиром загону.
Нині Дмитро повернувся до цивільного життя. Навчається, щоб бути
готовим знову стати в стрій.
Я зрозумів, що автоматник з мене короткий, тому що не маючи жодного військового уявлення,
просто жодного, користі з мене не так багато.
А якщо піти керувати дроном, то я розумію, що я як бойова одиниця,
буду набагато кориснішим для всього підрозділу і навіть регіону.
В іншій групі навчається Олена - швачка з 25-річним стажем.
Жінка виготовляє весільні вбрання. А ще прагне бути корисною для армії.
Я розумію, що я не зможу десь копати окопи, щось вантажити, якісь снаряди.
Але те, що я можу, чого зможу навчитися швидко…
Так сталося, що я сюди потрапила.
Олена - одна з небагатьох жінок на курсі. Зізнається: навчання дається нелегко,
але "літати" їй подобається.
Раніше мені здавалося: о, це круто - політати. А тепер я розумію,
наскільки це важливо, наскільки багато тут нюансів, які треба в голові тримати весь час.
І наскільки це корисно для того, щоб зберегти життя,
і наскільки це корисно, щоб… рубати русню.
І курсанти, й інструктори порівнюють управління дроном з керуванням автомобілем.
Наскільки це складно, перевіряю на собі. Допомагає ведучий інструктор Антон. Злітаємо.
- Головне правило - камерою від нас. Ми стартуємо камерою від нас,
отримуємо дрон теж камерою від нас, щоб ворог нас не побачив.
- А як далеко він може полетіти?
- Він не може летіти далеко, тому що ми не будемо летіти далеко, це ваш перший урок!
Керування схоже на гру на приставці. Інструктор підтверджує
- найкраще виходить у тих, хто полюбляє комп'ютерні ігри. Я не з таких.
- Ой, трошки корявенько…
- Супер, супер… Все знижуємо його.
Я його буду приймати. Все, що вам потрібно - лівий стік вниз і тримайте його вниз до упору.
Все, якось так.
- Взагалі нескладно, взагалі.
Насправді ж усе набагато серйозніше. Дрони називають "очима" армії.
Тож на війні аеророзвідники - одна з пріоритетних цілей для ворога.
Коли ти залишаєшся живим - ти професіонал. Тому що це дуже небезпечно.
Дрони бачить наш ворог, дрони - це пристрій який видає сигнал,
який можна пеленгувати, які наш ворог може знайти, і це дуже небезпечно.
Поки групи продовжують тренування, з'являються перші небезпеки.
Закінчуємо польотну програму на сьогодні, до побачення!
Ми не можемо зараз виконати, бо повітряна тривога, розумієш?
Можемо спробувати, але це так… ризиковано.
Під час повітряної тривоги починають працювати засоби радіоелектронної боротьби.
Вони плутають координати безпілотників. Тож навіть під час низьких польотів
дрон може "загубитися".
Он він над цим, над вітряком! Вправо летить, до нас!
Інструктори наголошують щодо пріоритетів: найперше - зберегти життя,
на другому місці - виконати місію. Останнє, але не менш важливе -
повернути "пташку" додому. Дрони по кілька тисяч доларів за кожен
вважають розхідним матеріалом на війні.
Але Антон Фролов обурюється, коли їх використовують не за призначенням.
Наприклад, аби скинути гранату на ворожі позиції.
Це відео, коли хтось кудись влучив - 99 разів він не влучив.
За ці 99 спроб скинути щось невдало він втратив декілька десятків дронів.
Тому що дрон перебуває на небезпечній висоті, коли він це робить, і його можна збити.
На початку війни середня тривалість життя одного дрона складала 3-5 хвилин.
Нині - значно більше. З квітня лише ця школа випустила сімсот
кваліфікованих операторів дронів. У сучасній війні технологій
люди, які ними керують, відіграють ключову роль.